[Music]
hey everybody
it's
tuesday yeah i guess i guess yeah
hopefully uh we're not going to like
lose the street it's gotten like gone
into the red a couple times while the
little preparation thing was on but it
just went for a second so hopefully yeah
we're talking about our connection
yeah um yeah we saw rollerball last
night so this one's about rollerball i
kind of feel like i can't remember who
it was but i remember
one or two people bringing that up it's
probably when we were doing like some
kind of 70s movies when we were doing
that a couple weeks back and so i was
like scrolling through i was like oh i'm
kind of in a 70s movie kind of mood uh
so i'm scrolling through like the amazon
prime stuff that's like you know the
free ones and i said so it was either
between rollerball or the parallax view
uh which i still want to watch i've seen
that one before but and i thought that i
had seen rollerball
but watching it i don't think i ever saw
it i've never seen rollerball
i could have sworn i saw it it was a lot
more it was a lot deeper more serious
movie than i thought it was yeah i was
thinking maybe i'm confused and it was
like death race 2000 or something
like this race that's what i mean yeah
that's what i was saying it's not really
like that no more like more like logan's
run yeah and uh soy and green like
soylent green yeah kind of like that
kind of dystopia kind of a future
futuristic dystopian movie
where the uh the earth's nation is kind
of like zardoz again the earth's nation
states we're just kind of taken over by
[ __ ]
eugenic style [ __ ] dystopian
corporations they run everything and
it's just kind of a
what do you call it uh um
uh an autocracy or a [ __ ] technocracy
it's like that
and uh this guy's a
pro athlete and he
played by james khan
who's uh looking good in this movie he's
[ __ ] young in this i had forgotten
that he was actually in the godfather a
couple years before this yeah so because
i was watching it i was like oh i don't
remember if i've seen him in anything
where he was this young but then i was
like oh yeah the godfather yeah
and he's like
look at his hair and it says yeah
because he hit this [ __ ] curly ass
[ __ ] block he's always had that hair
i said he's look at this look a little
little head and i was like
is he a little bit biracial or something
or is that a term what is that
so kind of looked out turns out he's
from new york uh
german jewish immigrant parents
and it [ __ ] dawned on me i'm looking
at him and i was like man if he had
the right hair black straight hair that
[ __ ] would have made a good
[ __ ] superman he's got a good chin
yeah he'd have made a good superman that
kind of fits he's got superman chin yeah
i never realized it i guess yeah he
didn't make a superman because i've i'm
used to seeing him older i guess like
from 1990 on because he was in misery
and stuff yeah um but physically he
would have made a good call
um now
kalel you know superman
[ __ ] chris reeves [ __ ] knocked it
out of the park just because
superman's got to have like a purity and
an innocence to it i mean khan is kind
of a [ __ ] tough guy james comey yeah
probably could have pulled it off but
he'd have to be kind of
superman you suspect of being a virgin
it's good yeah pretty much james cohn is
absolutely yeah
[Laughter]
superman like well i didn't want to hurt
you lois you know you know
but he made a pretty good superman yeah
you can imagine all kind of oh and i'm
sure people have imagined i'm sure
there's all kinds like slash section
about [ __ ] superman
and his magic dick yeah but uh yeah so
so yeah so i had thought i had seen
rollerball but i guess like we were
watching it and i hadn't seen it so this
came out in 1975. now this was actually
directed by norman jewison and i said oh
man i know that name
so i look him up he won three oscars
actually for in the heat of the night uh
fiddler on the roof
good flick uh and moonstruck all right
also a good flick and he also directed
agnes of god which i love that movie
sorry uh jesus christ superstar the
hurricane like for 1999 so he's directed
a [ __ ] ton of stuff all right so uh so
yeah so he directed this it's jewish
production jewesson he's doing [ __ ]
fiddler on the roof all the jewish he's
uh he's canadian or jewish and his uh
canadian guy yeah and uh so he
so this is actually oh that was my phone
okay that's it was either there was a
bomb getting ready to go off no it's
notification it's a notification or the
phone's ringing i'm sure it's like
nobody
yahoo coming again
yeah okay yeah the only the only phone
calls i ever get say spam risk on them
which is nice i like that they do that
now it either says spam risk or
telemarketer and i'm like oh thanks i
wasn't gonna answer it anyway but you
know uh so yeah so this was actually
based on a short story called rollerball
murder which is a dumb name but okay um
by william harrison and that came that
turned up in esquire magazine back in
1973 and the same guy that wrote the
short story which is pretty close to how
the movie turned out uh is also the guy
that wrote the screenplay
so why is my phone making that noise i
don't know man telemarketer is trying to
get you make it stop that's never
happened the whole time in the show
i know
well it's like yeah
why is it making that noise
that doesn't even sound like it's
ringing it sounds like it's just a
warning it sounds like you know what you
see that
it might be maybe it's an amber alert
maybe that's what it is is it an amber
alert your hat's on top of my [ __ ]
phone look at this so unprofessional
like i'm worried about that um yeah like
what ever alert their children are
missing children are missing it doesn't
look like there's no amber alert on here
i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
um yeah it's nobody it's it doesn't say
spam risk but it's not a phone number i
recognize so [ __ ] it i'm not answering
that
nobody says james comes also very good
in thief which i mentioned earlier i
want to see thief oh yeah like we were
talking about that too he says it's one
of the best heist movies of all time
yeah that was another one that was
another one that we wanted to see but uh
yeah so i didn't realize okay so i don't
remember i don't think they said this in
the movie because when we were watching
the movie we were like well what year is
this supposed to be because obviously
it's supposed to be distant future from
1975. so i looked it up on wikipedia
it's supposed to be 2018. yeah so yeah
remember back in 2018 back when you had
it when the when the whole world was
owned by six corporations well what they
do like the corporations there are six
of them and each of them is in charge of
a different thing like one big
corporation is like food companies
and one is energy corporation so they so
they have like a you know a monopoly on
each thing
and basically what they do
they've gotten rid of poverty they've
gotten rid of crime which you know that
sounds like a good thing but uh so
they've done that but
the kind of the message of the movie is
people have traded you know safety and
comfort for individuality sort of thing
it's i feel like it's not as
it doesn't seem quite as dystopian as
logan's run maybe but it's a similar
kind of vibe where people just have
really comfortable lives um you know
everybody seems to have a place to live
everybody seems to have enough food to
eat
they give them happy pills and that's
kind of that is kind of the [ __ ] idea
behind this movie khan's realizing that
people have given up freedom in exchange
for comfort
that's what the but that's the problem
with the society yeah and like the and
everybody's like uh base or urges if you
want to call them that i don't think
they ever say this outright but it's the
implication being that everyone's base
or urges are all
channeled into
rollerball like these matches which is
essentially it's a real game they did
come up with a i mean it's not a real
game but they did come up with a game
for the movie like that had rules and
everything and it's essentially a cross
between
roller derby
motocross
soccer
kind of
or football if you're not in the if
you're not american and
maybe something else but um yeah so it's
basically it's people going around and
roller skates and people on motorcycles
and this ball comes shooting out of this
pipe
and they have to pick it up and put it
in the other team's goal
and there's not really any
i guess at the start there's kind of
rules like you can get penalties and
stuff but as the movie goes on uh they
take some of the rules away particularly
because they want
uh james khan's character whose name is
jonathan e
um he's getting sort of like famous and
he's getting like bigger than the game
so they're keep tr they this is kind of
what starts him on his whole
uh you know journey throughout the movie
is that he can't figure out because he
doesn't want to retire because he really
likes playing the game and he really
likes being famous
um
and
but they they're trying to pressure him
to retire they're going to give him this
that and the other thing and they're
kind of threatening him hey if you don't
like something bad might happen and that
kind of stuff and he can't figure out
why they want him to do it but it's
basically because
they don't like the whole game was
uh was kind of set up
to
it's kind of a thing where nobody is
supposed to like excel at it it's just a
game where everyone is just like
supposed to beat the crap out of each
other everyone's just gonna come watch
it and cheer for their team or their you
know company or whatever and no one's
supposed to be like individualistic as
in famous like one person so he's gotten
too famous so they want to get like get
rid of it it's meant to kind of
demoralize the public right and kind of
beat you down and and a base you
you know yeah and it's and it's because
it's made up by the higher executives
and the higher executives look down
their noses at the game secretly they
think it's for dummies
you know like yeah that's a terrible
game it's just for the it's for the
rabble you know that that's yeah it's a
bread and circuses type of uh type of
situation
louis
that person trying to call so
desperately that that was sancho
that that was that was sancho man
you know sancho is right what are you
talking about that's your boyfriend
that's my boyfriend yeah
i have a boyfriend named sanchez yeah
it's it's you you wouldn't understand
it's a mexican thing
uh okay yeah sancho is like jody
who's jody jodie is uh the pig from
amnevil horror jody is always your
girlfriend's boyfriend
you didn't know about him that's jody
all right it's the same thing why jody i
don't know man i started in the army
they called him jody and then uh first
thing i think of a jody is the imaginary
pig sorry imaginary picture in mexico
you know the dude that's got your
girlfriend you don't even know about the
sancho
[Laughter]
well you learned something new every day
yeah sanchez got it
[Laughter]
call me sancho yeah yeah now four dro
down said rollerball is a great movie
but as tom said the same thing about
logan's run
star wars suddenly made it seem rather
dated feels more like a 60s movie in
some ways yeah it does it does yeah um
and the thing about it it's like
i don't know i i mean i really dug it
because i wasn't expecting i mean i was
just mostly expecting like i said like a
death race 2000 and it does have
you know two or three set pieces of you
know like a rollerball game that are
like pretty violent and people getting
knocked over and
beat up and [ __ ]
but
most of it is character [ __ ] you know
what i mean and i wasn't really
expecting that so like you said it
really does have a logan's run kind of
dystopian vibe to it and
it's not as over the top as that because
it does seem like james khan is just
kind of like
going through this investigation
of why they want him to quit because he
thinks something is going on
um so it has kind of more
i don't know it has more of like kind of
a weird like unsettling
kind of vibe i really like the one scene
where they're all at that party
you know what i mean yeah like and
they're all watching the [ __ ] on tv and
everybody's like super obsessed with it
and everybody's like looking at him
weird and it was like glancing it's like
i don't know it was like it had like a
really unsettling atmosphere to it also
so much paneling holy [ __ ] visually i
like the movie it takes me back to my
youth i mean out in southern california
every building every
cool up-to-date building in the 70s
looked like that
and it's just kind of which is funny
those buildings are all torn down now by
now probably but that's what they look
like and so to me it didn't look
futuristic look like going back in time
the thing that interested me when i was
watching the movie
i thought to myself
um
you know yeah this is a dystopian like
it seemed like the dudes
um especially if they were
uh athletes like the rollerball players
that they were really kind of lived in
luxury type of thing yeah um was it me
or was every single woman essentially a
hooker yeah yeah so i'm like so not not
so great for the ladies you're all
hookers
i didn't see any like women that had
well it was kind of like pro ball
athletes of today there's there's like
groupies right
and uh the groupies are kind of
associated with certain teams they
follow them around that actually that's
a real well no but i mean
but in this one because it was corporate
control they issued them to the dudes
that's what i was saying and they were
also spies
and um basically they took james khan
had a wife named ella yeah and they took
her yeah because one of the executives
wanted her she got assigned to us so
yeah so i'm sitting there thinking well
did any like none of the executives were
women were they i think they were all
men oh yeah so i'm pretty sure that
every woman in this was you had to do
what you were told like you just got
issued like here here's your boyfriend
go go [ __ ] that old man well
corporations are run like armies a
modern army of today is a copy of a
corporation that happened in world war
ii it's literal
generals got impressed
with mass production because that was
winning the war and they said well how
are we going to run
this army and they ran an army like a
corporation well the corporation also
kind of runs like an army
so you have a position you have
assignments you're constantly being told
what your next job is it's it's you know
what i mean they keep you busy
and in this story
the women were issued they were kind of
like a match made that was your
assignment yeah they didn't yeah they
didn't have any like choice about where
they were yeah i don't think anybody had
a choice about anything it was
totalitarian
and uh it was kind of like in the soy
and green soylent green if you rented an
apartment it came with a woman they came
with a woman yeah but if but she
considered that to be a [ __ ] kind of
like a good job because if she didn't
wasn't they called her furniture she
just came with the apartment
if she wasn't living there she'd have
been out in the damn outside in the
ghetto and they were all killing each
other and starving to death you know
outside those yeah it was kind of it was
kind of the same thing here i kind of
feel like i don't know because they
didn't really go into other than the
executives who are kind of like the 1
and the athletes yeah who were kind of
given all of those like really nice
houses they were issued women like and
if you got sick of one or if you know if
one you know they would or if somebody
else wanted that one they would switch
them around yeah um so they would just
like issue you a girlfriend and they
would and she would live there and like
you know do all your housework and [ __ ]
like yeah you didn't choose your
girlfriend
that's what i'm saying yeah that's what
i'm saying she just showed up she just
showed up and it was the upper executive
center there yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying they were kind of spies too
yeah that's i got that feeling
that they were like watching you their
real job was to report back to the
[ __ ] upper executives what you were
doing yeah so she wasn't your girlfriend
she was more kind just like a spy she
was siri you know like yeah
you know what i mean
you pretended that it was yours but it
actually belonged to google you know
it's like that that did the woman that
played his wife
um
what she was a she was in one of the
james bond movies wasn't she i think she
was i think she wasn't she man with a
golden gun or yeah something like that i
can't remember
uh what her name is but i'm she i know
she was i know i'd seen her before also
the guy in this
who plays
kind of the second highest dude like on
the team whose name is moonpie
which i couldn't get over like all one
word
um before we get off that subject though
the woman
you have to understand that this is
during the time of the cold war they're
making parallels between a corporate
controlled society and communism all
right because when the state takes over
the means production
that's communism
well it's kind of the same thing when
the means of production take over the
state that's corporatism communism is
actually just like a form of corporatism
is what they're saying
and that even goes to those women
in the soviet union they talked about
how they were going to nationalize women
they didn't ever go get around to doing
it it was like even that was too
inhumane for the [ __ ]
ussr but they had discussed it in in i
think it might have been in in the
stalin era
should women become nationalized
which means should they be issued
that's some weird [ __ ] when you think
about it uh some some in cells and mgtow
say that yeah that it's like that's
that's how you keep us from because yeah
because they were saying well it's kind
of unfair that guys have to [ __ ]
compete for a mate shouldn't they be
issued a mate
yeah and then they were thinking well we
have to have children for we have to
have children for they don't care how we
feel about it no well nobody cared about
anything they would just be given to you
and then they would tell you how many
children you had to have for the welfare
of the state
and for the welfare of the people
because you need replacement population
so
in a totalitarian society your personal
desires and happiness oh [ __ ] no this is
all about the the masses and the people
and the state and everything and it's
your duty to do all this stuff like like
a
like a military duty
you have to get you have to be with this
dude you have to have his children not
for him and not for you but for the for
the people you're going to say like
they're the stake one of the two and
then they'll say the people is the state
they play all these damn games word
games just getting you to obey so that's
what they were talking about there with
the women i just wanted to mention that
that's what that was the meaning of that
well yeah i mean i was just trying to
remember like when i was watching it
because i said yeah it seemed like all
the women had been yeah that was all i
wanted they were just kind of like
property of the corporation but
everybody was property of the
corporation you just did everybody did
what they were told but yeah so the guy
that plays moonpie
who is one of those dudes that is like
one of the 70s you know seven
with the big [ __ ] stash and
everything
um i had seen him like a hulk hogan
actually i had seen him before
and i was just kind of for a second he
looks kind of like the dude that was in
dario argento's inferno yeah but i was
like no that's not him but i was like
what the [ __ ] i just saw him in
something the other day his name his
john beck he was in he was the dad and
[ __ ] audrey rose that's where i saw
him before and he was also on dallas and
he was in like a [ __ ] ton of tv like i
looked up his wikipedia page so it was
like [ __ ] tons of tons of [ __ ] that
he was in but he was just like bugging
me the whole time because i'm like where
the [ __ ] have i seen that [ __ ]
before pretty much everybody in this
i don't know i kind of feel like most of
the main character well john houseman is
in it too he kind of plays
like this main
uh mr bartholomew i think his name is
and he's kind of like the main
big old guy executive at the energy
corporation which is based in houston or
where houston used to be and that's the
team that jonathan e is on
and uh so that's there's a lot of
interactions with them
so he's great he's always great uh
interestingly interesting fact about
this movie this is the first major
hollywood movie that actually credited
its stunt people
good can you believe that they hadn't
done that prior to 1975 i'm like oh so
these people turn up on the set and like
risk their lives like to make your stars
look good and you can't even like put
them in the [ __ ] credits yeah god
damn it took like till 1975. and on and
they did it because um you know all the
people that showed up for you know to do
stunt work were obviously like real
motocross guys real roller derby guys
you know real athletes uh because they
actually had to play
this game yeah um because you know they
didn't have cgi or anything like that i
remember when i was a kid this movie was
around it had a reputation in when i was
a little kid as
on the school yard [ __ ] people would
talk about how brutal this movie was
and that their parents wouldn't let them
watch it and all that kind of stuff
and it was kind of the same situation
later on as mad max won it was a movie
you heard about you heard that it was
bad your parents wouldn't let you watch
it it was too brutal and violent it was
too easy so this was you when i watched
it you could see how this was kind of
like
a mad max movie in some ways when it
came to like uh
live-action violence and uh involving
like uh well in this case motorcycles
motorcycles and roller skaters it now
it's not as film is good it's not as
epic as mad max one it's not as visceral
it's a little more cerebral
it's kind of like a movie of the 60s or
anything else um
but it i could understand how this movie
made an impression in the day
in the day i could see it but like like
i mean by today's standards it's not
that violent or brutal no um you know it
i think the brutality mostly comes from
knowing that those people were doing
those stunts for real
and you know and some of it did look
like it [ __ ] hurt you know what i
mean because they're punching each other
in the face and pulling people off
motorcycles on roller skates and [ __ ]
like that but it wasn't that much
different than regular roller derby
yeah well see that's what i was thinking
because i had i had a friend that did
roller roller derby like years ago and
it's you know
roller derby just on its own
uh is pretty rough yeah you know what i
mean and you like see some like pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ] i mean adding motorcycles
and yeah the the flying ball and [ __ ]
like that which kind of like highlight
now that i'm thinking about it yeah kind
of like highlight and [ __ ] but it was
a steel ball and a special mitt that you
caught kind of like a catcher's mitt and
i remember as a kid the whole motorcycle
angle we were like oh man motorcycles
but not knowing much about motorcycles
back in those days it wasn't pretty
impressive when i see the motorcycles
today they're honda cub 125s with some
sheet metal on them to hide what they
are they're little they're motor
scooters basically they're not real yeah
they didn't want those are actual real
stunt people they didn't want them
getting killed you're right they're moto
scooters and uh this which which tells
me that the speeds were not high
i mean the roller skaters are next to
the damn bike the motorcycles like i
read in some of the sequences they were
doing uh they were going about 40 miles
about 40. yeah so you're not which you'd
still get [ __ ] up if you had an
accident yeah but you're not talking 70
80 right 90 you know that would be i
like that they did a lot of the stunts
in real time because you know how
sometimes in sort of cheaper movies
where they would do like car stunts or
motorcycle stunts and then they would
speed the film up but it's really really
obvious that they filmed the speed and
like uh sped the film up to make it look
like the cars or motorcycles were going
faster so i kind of like that they
didn't do this didn't do that here
because this actually they play it like
a real game they play it in real time
and uh i heard that the stunt people
liked the game so much that they would
just play it when it wasn't even being
filmed yeah you know what i mean so they
would just like get on the skates and
[ __ ] run all around the around the
[ __ ]
it was pretty good my only criticism of
it is that they didn't
they didn't have the cameras technology
of of today back then of course so you
couldn't get a lot of shots that really
you probably should have gotten during
some of these fights the real low angle
shots happening at pretty high speeds
the speed should have seemed a little
faster i think
mad max 1 was able to accomplish that
just with [ __ ] no budget by getting a
dude on the back of a damn motorcycle
that huge camera holding it with his
hands
[ __ ] and it was pretty impressive
what
mad max one did with no money
um
i would like to have seen shots more
like that but they're just working with
what they had you know
i mean this movie i'm not really sure
actually uh how much this cost to make
it was a it was a you know a major
studio but uh you know i don't know how
much it costs to make they actually shot
it interestingly the director was
canadian um even though it's supposed to
be most of it's supposed to be said in
houston uh they actually shot most of
the exteriors and all the the game parts
in munich
so a lot of those buildings that you see
they're supposed to be like these
futuristic buildings stuff that was all
and that was all in munich and a lot of
the interiors were shot in london so i
don't even think they shot any of it in
the united states moz adams was in two
bond movies yeah mod adams
yeah yeah oh i got it right
damn i impressed myself sometimes
hernandez
so so if you ever go there
they just let you right over the border
she'll like relax i'm an honorary
mexican yeah i got i got [ __ ]
documentation
from an actual mexican actual man
he's got
mexican authenticity card himself
the [ __ ] dudes at the border like
what
where
[Laughter]
oh my god all right so oh one one scene
that i wanted to discuss a little bit
with this just because it's so weird
you know the one scene where when james
khan is doing this investigation as to
he thinks there's some kind of big
conspiratorial thing he's like look why
do they want me to retire so bad i think
something weird is going on so he's kind
of going along these little paths trying
to figure out like trying to get his
trainer to get information and all this
other kind of [ __ ] now at one point
he goes to some place that's supposed to
be a library
and the woman is basically like well
it's not really a library per se it's
just kind of like a repository of
information but all of the books in the
world
have been
pretty much taken away from everywhere
and all stored in geneva or so she says
so that's where they all go because all
the books are being digitized
essentially i don't think they use that
word but that's what they were saying
they're all being digitized and they're
all in genevas that's where all the
books are so he ends up going to geneva
and he finds out that there are no books
there either they've all already been
integrated into
what is essentially i don't know if i'd
necessarily call it an internet but it's
kind of like an ai
super computer but it's like a tank of
water yes fluid but it can talk and it's
alive too yeah but it definitely doesn't
work that well and
yeah and it's like oh it's like oh we
lost the whole entire 13th century
oopsie you know what i mean and it seems
like the so that was like a really weird
scene and they didn't go back to that no
and it was not resolved what it was they
were talking about with that i don't
know what that meant i don't maybe was
just supposed to entertain us but he
went to go ask the thing a question and
it just refused to answer the question i
mean i guess the point of it was that
like all the world's knowledge that had
been in books and stuff is now
essentially lost because they put it all
into this
super computer fluid thing
and it doesn't work and it doesn't know
anything now
uh so they're like oh well so i guess
like all the all the world's knowledge
has essentially like been flushed down
the toilet maybe that's what they were
getting at i wouldn't care i would have
yeah i would have liked for them to go
to go back to that like one time because
that was just like so weird and they
didn't refer to it again the computer
was acting like it was afraid to answer
and that guy was beating on it yeah some
weird [ __ ]
yeah that's right he's like
yeah
just like a normal person does when your
[ __ ] doesn't work that's what i do with
my computer when it doesn't work it was
threatening it yeah it was alive yeah
but it was some kind of living fluid
it wasn't it wasn't quite explained
um not with by
technology that we know of and they
didn't seem to understand it either
though yeah they didn't really they i
it's kind of like they were just
throwing all the information in there
and hoping for the best and it was just
all getting jumbled up and lost and they
didn't really seem all that concerned
about it yeah um i wonder if that was
gone more into in the short story now
i'd be kind of interested to read the
short story i haven't read the story but
i'm it's the same guy that wrote the
screenplay right so i'm assuming most
and i've heard that the short story is
actually pretty close to how the movie
turned out so maybe it's like
maybe it's described more in the story
maybe i'm not really sure it's probably
just a message that corporate con
corporate controlled societies don't
care about the past at all they only
care about the future profits that's
kind of what i got from this that's the
meaning i took away from it that's kind
of what i got from that it might be in
their advantage to erase history so that
might have been they might have been
doing that on purpose
they're telling everybody that they're
saving things but they're actually
destroying history yeah that way
they can spin any narrative they want
yeah that's kind of like what i got from
it but yeah i would have i would have
kind of been interested to see like that
gone into a little bit more
um dominic says i have rollerball it's
still one of my favorites mostly for the
action sequences great stunt work and
sound yeah i agree with that uh the
computer guy was ralph richardson i
think i think it yeah i think it was and
it was just like i said it was just one
scene and it wasn't really
it was a weird-ass scene but yeah this
is a very
i didn't i didn't realize going into it
because like you said i thought it was
going to be more like a death race 2000
almost like a cheesy
sports action type of thing and it has
sequences like that but most of it's not
like that most it's like pretty cerebral
yeah it's it's it's kind of a
high-minded type it's more along the
lines of [ __ ]
um
soylent green yeah
but in some ways better than soylent
green i liked this a lot better i like
soylent green too but it wasn't as good
as i remembered it being like when i
rewatched it recently i like this one a
lot better can't re-watch soylent green
if you know what soil and green is
yeah because it's not because yeah
because the whole time like it comes on
you're like it's people yeah it's people
it's people yeah it's obvious
and it's obvious what they're doing and
it takes them like way too long
to figure it out
to know that they're [ __ ] taking the
bodies of the dead and or killing people
and also turning and turning them into
soil and green
that's the thing it's yeah it's i i
think it's one of those movies that if
you already know the twist then it's not
that it's not quite as enjoyable yeah um
you know
i and i was going to say another movie
that's kind of the flip side of that is
planet of the apes but it's like even
though you know what the ending is
everybody knows you blow it up you know
everybody knows that but that's still
like a fun as hell movie even if you
know what the twist is
um sort of like green not so much i
yeah like you said i think the last time
i watched it i was just the whole time i
was just kind of like how long is it
going to take them to figure out that
like they're eating people i mean come
on get on the clue boss but uh yeah it
seemed to take way too long it's all
boomer stuff man
the u.n and all these [ __ ] trilateral
commissions and all these [ __ ]
international [ __ ] councils with the
u.n were writing up all these papers and
people were reading them and they were
coming up with these movies like zardoz
and it's all apocalyptic [ __ ] zardoz
rollerball would fit in there
uh
like in
soylent green would fit in there
a mega man would fit in there yeah this
one i feel like it's not
post-apocalyptic in the sense of there
wasn't like a nuclear war or anything
but it seemed like they talked about the
corporate wars and they kept talking
about like how nasty they were so there
might have been something like that but
there's really no evidence of that now
like now everybody seems to like live in
really luxurious well the people they
show the people they show yeah regular
people were just basically living in
cubicles watching tv i think that's what
it was yeah probably which would have
made it a situation kind of like uh what
what aj called prison planet or
metaverse or um
uh the [ __ ] thing from uh what do you
call it damn thing from the matrix where
you're just in a damn
pod and you're in a vr virtual reality
yeah it's
a low-tech version of the damn pods you
stay in the [ __ ] room and watch tv
that's what it seemed like they were
talking about people just watching it
yeah they were all like just watching
the rollerball yeah it was it was like
the world cup but everybody watched it
and everybody was really really invested
and i'm imagining that the rest of the
television programs were just mindless
[ __ ]
although they didn't show any did they
show it no i think that's all they
showed was like the was the rollerball
game
but so that was i guess the main
entertainment so everyone was into it so
they're talking about welfare you just
sitting in your house watching tv
getting free [ __ ] and then just pumping
[ __ ] to you that's the same as the
matrix you're just in a pod and they're
pumping a fake reality to you that you
think is real through virtual reality
it's all the same idea that's what
metaverse they're talking about great
reset same thing it's all coming out of
the same group in literature
and it's also written sci-fi anyway the
people saying this are not [ __ ] the
people that come up with these ideas are
[ __ ] it's fantasy
basically i should know
that
they did a couple video games based on
this uh a few of them i don't think they
were official but they looked like they
were kind of trying to rip it off um but
which i've heard are kind of fun
uh also they did a remake of this in the
2000s i can't remember 2008 i want to
say uh which i've heard was terrible
because basically
they
uh they didn't really i think they did
do the whole dystopian thing but i think
they tried to make it more like an
extreme like action movie which is kind
of like not the point of the movie no uh
so it seemed like the remake kind of
missed the whole entire point of what
the original movie was saying because
the original movie it you know the the
sport was supposed to be like brutal and
[ __ ] up and everything like that
because it was supposed to be like bad
it was supposed to be like yeah you know
it wasn't supposed to be like celebrated
really i mean that's kind of the point
that the movie was making so i feel like
the remake i haven't seen it but from
other reviews that i've seen of it and
like reading about it it seems like it
kind of missed the point and it really
didn't do very well i feel like
you know it came out and everyone was
like meh this one no the the remake oh
the remake yeah
people forgot about it yeah it was just
it's like a completely so yeah so
definitely if you're gonna see anything
rollerball you should see the original
one because i've heard the remake is
just
like yeah
this
wasn't bad it was good it's just that
like i said me and fourth drawer down
[ __ ] pointed out star wars came out a
couple years later and kicked everyone's
ass out kicked everybody's ass all these
movies were quickly forgotten they just
immediately looked they immediately
looked outdated and fake
yeah i mean that just kind of like
stomped on everyone's testicles that
movie yeah
you know in a good way but right
you can't make movies you can't make
movies like logan's run anymore like
after star wars came out you just can't
louis says 2002 the remake came out and
he said it was god-awful yeah that's
right i've never i have not heard a
single person well most people just
forgot it existed
but of people that have mentioned it i
have not heard a single but everyone
just said it was just like a piece of
[ __ ] from my memory that was in in
in general around the same time
as [ __ ] um
battlefield earth came out and jenny
makes fun of me but i would want a
[ __ ] copy of battlefield earth on
blu-ray
or i couldn't even sit through that old
movie yeah and i want to do a [ __ ]
serious review
of [ __ ] battlefield earth
i want to give it
the respect it deserves
which is
zero what are you talking about
no they're actually actually okay
there are other like forest whitaker
being in it
i love him there were some good ideas in
it all right that could have been really
good it was good ideas in a lot of
movies that doesn't mean they're good
poofy i could have fixed battlefield if
they had me around but the problem with
battlefield earth is that it had to
somehow conform to scientology's crazy
value system which is
somehow that's gonna kind of [ __ ] up the
flow of the movie and it's gonna
but there's things about that movie that
i [ __ ] like the star of that movie
looks just like david miscavige you know
he got who's the leader of the church
and you know they chose that actor
because that david was cabbage looks
like that that guy is supposed to be
david miscavige saving the earth from
the [ __ ] s from the cyclos the cyclos
yeah i can't wait until david miscavige
saves yeah and then you had yeah
yeah
can't wait for that
and then you yeah
you had the [ __ ] aliens i liked the
aliens i just thought they were [ __ ]
funny you know like they were only
worried about their bonuses and they
were real corporate
well the thing about battle rat little
fella the thing about battlefield earth
i think battlefield earth had the same
problem that a lot of sort of like
christian propaganda type movies have
is that when you're hemmed in by this
particular
message that you want to send or this
particular like religion is kind of you
can't really
make a good piece of art because you're
too worried about ticking off like all
these particular boxes and i think the
same thing happened with battlefield
earth that i mean that movie like i said
i can't i'll sit through some through
some [ __ ] now like i'll sit through
some shitty ass movies
um
i just couldn't
i just couldn't get into it i don't know
like i don't know what it wasn't even
funny or stupid enough for me to be
entertained i was just kind of like i
just can't handle it i enjoyed it
because i understood what i was seeing i
thought it was fascinating kind of like
watching
uh uh what it's kind of like watching
that north korean [ __ ] monster movie
sorry it's like watching pogba sorry
which is i like to focus
like a north korean monster movie yeah
but that's
it's just a product that comes out of
[ __ ] scientology and it's trying to
disguise itself as not being scientology
and it's being a cool sci-fi yeah yeah
and and and [ __ ] you got you got
older plus it was giving me motion
sickness it seemed like every shot was
like that or like that i'm like knock it
off with the dutch angles gotcha they
had a lot of kind of cheesy um
cgi didn't look too good at it and then
as soon as it came out and the public
didn't like it [ __ ] scientology
disavowed oh that piece of [ __ ] oh no we
had nothing to do with that which makes
me even like it even more that they try
to dis which is weird because you would
think i mean i would have thought i
would have thought that the first go-to
would have been
you guys just don't understand it
because we're too awesome for you or you
guys sabotaged or you guys sabotaged it
or they or they would try to play the
victim because that's usually what ends
up no they admit we had to do with that
piece of [ __ ] we don't know anything
about that movie
[Laughter]
i'm like man i'm gonna buy that [ __ ]
okay i'm not i'm not buying it
i'm not giving i'm not giving those
[ __ ] any of my money they probably
don't sell it
yeah they do they do sell it you can get
every movie nowadays all right i didn't
know what studio owns it or what the
distribution i don't know who likes it
either but
i guess i guess scientology prod doesn't
own the distribution of it so it's not
well no because they yeah yeah i mean i
thought it was like it was a pretty big
uh release so i thought there was
actually some production company behind
it right
somebody got suckered into making that
piece of crap it was bad but it was kind
of so bad that it was good in a certain
way see i don't think it was though and
one of the reasons why it was so bad is
because
everybody knew it was scientology that
made it you know that's
so that that kind of tainted the
audience
yeah they were trying to like pull one
over on people like people were dumb and
they didn't know that that's where that
was coming from but with me that kind of
attracted me to it i wanted to see what
these [ __ ] with these [ __ ]
freakazoids
well see i think that's why i didn't
like it because i was expecting it to be
like way way stupider
and like wait you know what i mean and
it's like it wasn't even like it was
stupid but it wasn't stupid enough
to be fun you know what i mean it was
just stupid and it's like i couldn't a
lot of it was kind of boring too i
thought it was kind of boring
uh i i didn't think it was boring i was
kind of interested in what the hell was
happening didn't it yeah
i mean but maybe boring isn't the word
maybe maybe it was just kind of like i
didn't care enough like to follow it i
think it's more what it what it was with
you like they didn't really get me to
care about it i thought it was a great
premise man and i thought it's like well
it's like if i thought that this was
going to go full on like bat [ __ ] insane
then i might like sit here and watch it
but well there was like it wasn't there
were some parts of that movie that were
totally implausible but you just have to
go okay
because if you don't accept it then the
movie can't continue
yeah i'm talking about your movie
okay all right yeah
okay you can teach a caveman to fly
okay sounds good
maybe maybe it's a really smart game man
well there was the least be hitting it
with his head there was the learning
machines but like we're getting again
we're going on that's another movie
well yeah that's another movie what does
that
you should like you should save that for
uh
for that but like i said it's if i'm
gonna sit through that i'm gonna have to
drink a lot
for me to sit louie says that was one of
the few movies he walked out of the
theater yeah yeah
i don't think i've ever walked out of
the thing i've wanted to a couple of
times i almost wanted to [ __ ] walk
out of [ __ ] uh
last jedi
i think the only time i wanted to walk
out a couple times i think okay the two
times i can remember
one time i wanted and this was a long
time ago
um
end of days
uh one with arnold schwarzenegger yeah
that was terrible it was so bad
and uh
i didn't really i didn't little swears
by that i didn't really want to go see
it but uh my my husband at the time like
was real into action movies and he's
like look there's an action movie and
it's also like the devil and i was like
okay whatever so like we go to see it
and i'm just like oh my god this is so
[ __ ] stupid and it's like i really
wanted to leave like halfway through but
i didn't um the other movie that i
wanted what was the other one oh [ __ ]
rob zombies halloween yeah sancho called
you sancho called me yeah again i guess
so man he's stalking me that sancho yeah
[Music]
end of day this was unwatchable so was
your racer
that was see i didn't even bother
watching that was that was another i've
heard that was also terrible watchable
i've heard that and i like arnold
schwarzenegger's movies except that he's
got some out there that are just
unwatchable
yeah at least he got his [ __ ] together
later and was in some good [ __ ]
yeah
god damn sancho he's an awful persistent
isn't it
he's waiting for that next batch of
pictures
i guess
i've just lift up your shirt
i don't know who that is it's not it's
not anybody it's somebody from uh
volusia county because that's that's not
even this um
this
campaign exchange yeah that's that's 386
that's what they're saying bring it down
i guess they want to [ __ ] hear uh
yeah they gave john travolta a butterfly
excuse to wear built up shoes yeah yeah
i [ __ ] i i [ __ ] enjoyed travolta's
performance i enjoyed his performance
and i'm not [ __ ] on john travolta
because he's good in some stuff
but
yeah that was a ridiculous move it was
ridiculous but it wasn't ridiculous
enough for me to like it yeah all right
so uh we're pretty much done with
rollerball yeah okay yeah uh but yeah if
you have amazon prime uh they have
rollerball on right now for free for
free to me so that's how we ended up
watching it because i that's one
commercial in the beginning on a free
ones for all amazon for on amazon yeah
yeah yeah i mean 2b is different like 2b
has got commercial is completely free
yeah but because you know amazon prime
you got to pay for like every month but
yeah uh but yeah so rollerball was on
there so that's how we ended up watching
it because i remember i can't remember
who it was i'm sorry but i remember at
least one person maybe two people like
brought up rollerball when we were
talking about some of the 70s movies and
i'd like i said i could have sworn that
i saw it but when we were watching i'm
like yeah i'm pretty sure i didn't
[ __ ] see this camp guy liked a racer
he said it had good stunts a good story
i didn't like it race i didn't see it
there was something about a race i think
by that time i was so used to seeing um
arnold in some kind of a sci-fi action
type role that that one was was did have
a sci-fi element
i think i think his best really great
movie old-school type movie was the one
with with the damn clones was the name
of that [ __ ] thing
i don't know you bring it up a lot but i
can't remember either sixth day or fifth
day i liked that one that was kind of
like an old school arnold schwarzenegger
that one wasn't bad actually i liked it
yeah but yeah there yeah that was his
last final great
arnie flick i mean i feel like end of
days that even had gabriel byrne in it i
think and i love gabriel byrne but he
even he couldn't even save it yeah it's
just like oh well what are you gonna do
we had a good soundtrack though and good
[ __ ] score in the beginning it
sounded all impressive kind of like a
real
like almost kind of like something out
of damn um the omen or something real
satanic sound yeah i kind of wish they
had gone more in an omen direction and
lesson in like an action movie the final
scene when he's fighting the devil and
[ __ ] that one that one was a little bit
better but
my disbelief is totally [ __ ] shot at
this point by the time that this and i
feel like that came out like right
around the same and maybe i'm
remembering this wrong but i feel like
that came out right around the same time
as like another kind of satanic movie
called stigmata that had patricia
arquette in it and that was like way way
better probably um because i think i saw
that one in the theater too and i
remember liking that one much more was
that the one with the gabriel burn i
kind of feel like gabriel byrne was in
enough days
who the [ __ ] was who else was in
stigmata then [ __ ] it was patricia arcat
i'm sure but i can't remember who else
was in it anyway uh but yeah so go watch
rollerball if you haven't seen it uh you
know jamescon jamescon is pretty cool in
it and it's a pretty cool [ __ ] movie
it was like but way better than i
expected actually yeah even though i
thought i'd seen it before but i guess i
didn't uh so yeah so uh tomorrow's
wednesday right so tomorrow is episode
night yeah we're going to be doing
zodiac revisited revisiting the zodiac
that won the patreon poll by a landslide
yeah because some new stuff's come out
about the uh the zodiac yeah we'll get
to the bottom of that we'll see how
we'll see how that is i'll probably what
i'll probably do is i'll probably do
like a just an overview of the case as a
whole and then we'll get into like all
the new [ __ ] and talk about some [ __ ]
like that so that should be fun so yeah
uh come on by tomorrow at 5 p.m thanks
everybody for dropping by today and
we'll see you guys tomorrow evening